hello everyone in hello everyone in the
hot breath averse this is hot breath
live this is where you get to ask your
favorite comedians your favorite
questions and today is a hot breath
favorite she was guest number five and
then guest number 100 and something and
now we are back with the one and only
Mia Jackson everyone give her a round of
applause please give her a round of
applause yay me lately turn on the
applause sound effect here we go yeah
alright
Oh Carli sherek already says hello hello
and she says hi guinness she says hi to
my dog in the background yes yes that if
you watch me as YouTube interview with
us my dog actually makes an appearance
in that one as well so it's worth a
gander but just just off the jump here
first off Mia Jackson one of my favorite
comedians just in comedy in general and
absolute just force to be reckoned with
on the stage so if we could just give
them a brief like introduction to you
who you are how we got to where we are
you know the basics all right well hey
I'm Mia Jackson and a half wouldn't
people stop messaging me I'm my sister
she's messaging right now but I'm Mia
Jackson I let's see I started in I just
thought it'd been Athens Georgia mm-hmm
and then I went to Atlanta and at the
moment at the moment where I'm currently
located I you know I'm kind of mostly in
New York I'm not there at this moment
today because well you've seen the news
thank God I thank ya I'm currently
hanging out in the DC area for the
moment yes I'm quarantine but what else
what else do people need to know a
minute last last November I had a Comedy
Central half-hour come out so that was
pretty cool
and I'm actually supposed to be on
something I think this Sunday according
to some YouTube thing that I saw it's
gonna be on Comedy Central a thing
called this is stand-up yeah so I just
saw an article about that yeah
congratulations I saw an article about
that's great last year and I was like oh
it's out this weekend yeah
congratulations and Carly says she loves
the gold background so Thank You Carly
just let me know me too let me tell you
how this chamber I was doing a live in
another room and I had a another
background set up but the background was
just covering my quarantine snacks and
when I was filled out it was stacks of
water and in body armor juice and all
this other kind of stuff and I'm like oh
yeah so this is a full set up against an
actual wall and there's nothing behind
me but a wall oh my gosh it fell down in
the middle of the live oh I was just
talking like oh yeah and I was like oh
you know yes
no oh just just yeah I'm like a straight
up quarter it would even that much stuff
but that's what it looked like so I've
made sure that this is this is secure it
is pinned into and the thing is this is
one of my boyfriend is photographers or
this one of his backdrops and he told me
before
yeah and he told me beforehand when I
put it on so he was like yo do not use
masking tape to put up your back rounded
up like he's like he was on the side he
haven't walked me he was like see so
here we are with the secure gold
background yeah when we when we did our
last interview together you had just
moved to the DC area
we're like commuting back and forth to
New York and now not currently at this
moment but now were you living in New
York yeah yes I've been there and I
still pretty much split time you know
back and forth but I'm you know in being
in Georgia I'm just on the road a lot
and just you know in New York a good bit
of time these days so yeah that's a big
popular question we get a lot of comics
asking is like what what went into that
decision so many comics like well when
do I know when I'm ready to move to New
York or LA
what was that decision process for you
well you know what the main thing was
really just that one of my friends had a
room available and I was like okay I'll
just read your room make it sound so
easy
okay it wasn't that easy but no it was
um it was what I'm saying you know where
I think anybody that is pursuing comedy
eventually that's gonna come up
somebody's like when I go next to I you
know which which one do I go to and for
me you know I've been in Atlanta for a
long time I just kind of and this was
for me and again and that's what I
always try to preface most things by
because sometimes you know you'll get
different pieces of advice from people
but you know coz some people go and I do
people's does happen some people would
go to those places before they're really
ready to go and then you end up
struggling a whole lot harder than what
you probably needed to do but I do feel
like if if you feel that you have
reached a point where you have kind of
done everything that you can do in
whatever city you're in then that may be
a good time to go into looking to make
the move but I mean I think if
somebody's been doing comedy for like a
year or two I mean yeah you could go you
could go
you could go to LA you can go to New
York but it is going to be a whole lot
harder I mean it's hard to go even being
established but it's like at least
have you know have a good amount of
material in the bank before Wow to make
that to make that move because it's I
mean stage time in both places is really
hard hard to get and just from the
friends I know that live in LA is even
harder in LA to get stage time because
you know at least in New York you know
because you have the club system and all
this stuff where you have to get past or
worked and work in the clubs and things
like that but it's also like Brooklyn
has its own comedy scene and it's just
so many people have bar shows and it's
all these different kind of things you
can do just to be on stage at New York
so at least you could get on stage I
mean it's not super super easy but it's
nice to go like hey I've been in Atlanta
for three four years I've been in
Chicago for three four years and I'm
working and I've done all the places in
those Dole cities and I'm getting that
quality station I'm in and then if you
feel ready at that point then sure go
ahead and make the move but I mean I've
I know people that have gone too early
and then they go oh I went that I needed
to come back because stage yeah how long
have been doing comedy before you moved
up there oh god probably like 14 years
15 years about Manuka a long time but
but full-time I've actually only been a
full-time comic for six years now so
I've been full-time for six years so I
was full time for four before I went for
full-time 5:05 before I was a full time
coming for five years before I went to
New York yeah yeah cuz you yeah I
remember you had you'd been on you've
made a few TV appearances and you had
been opening for Amy Schumer and this
was all before you moved to New York
this is all before I moved I had let me
see within the time of me going
full-time like the what is it so I went
full-time in April
of 2014 and then by March or April of
the next year I did see the night of
Last Comic Standing and then 2017 I was
new faces jfl 2018 I did the thing with
epics and then 2019 the Comedy Central
half-hour came out but also in 2018 in
part of 2019 I was on any Schumer's tour
how did your life change once you got up
to New York was it partly because we had
Sean Patton on here and he was giving
just like the raw reality he did not
sugarcoat moving to New York like at any
level but he was like especially if
you're trying to move up there to figure
it out he's like here's the reality
what's gonna happen what was your
reality
I guess 14 years in having a lot of
established connections what was still
what was that transition like um well if
there's so I always you know try to make
the distinction that you know I was you
know very lucky you know
blessed whatever works people want to
use that when things come together you
know so I was so like I luckily like I
gotten passed at the Comedy Cellar
before I moved there so that was so that
really was really really helpful to be
able to you know that happened like back
in that actually happened back in late
2016
so um yes I would still kind of go back
and forth hours like the time I did the
last time I was all with you guys named
week said when I was commuting back and
forth like that was part of I was going
back and forth to UM to New York so it
was very very lucky it was a very very
lucky shot that I was able to get in
because I was able to to work and get on
stage you know in the Comedy Cellar it's
just like the absolute best and it's
three different rooms that you can get
honest I was able to get stage time but
being there was really helpful for me
because when other people you know a
bunch of big
comics working out working there so a
lot of those people run shows at other
places and then they were like oh you
should come do my show with this spotter
come to my show at this place come to my
show here and then there were other
people who I knew just from having been
on the road and just haven't worked with
them it you know when I was in Atlanta
or wherever I was just doing shows would
be someone that I work with that would
go oh well now you're here will come
come to my show so a lot of that was you
know and again I think some of it just
happened to for me because I had already
had a lot of experience but then they're
also just those things where it's like
shows where's people who don't know me
at all and then I still have to you know
I have to prove myself on those shows
too or somebody's like oh like they
might have just taught me one night
somewhere they're like oh can you come
do my spot so I still you have to go
through that thing of oh I'm a new
person doing a new spot and you and
shows can be pretty much anywhere in New
York and um you know and it's like oh
this shows in a small coffee shop where
people are still currently drinking
right now and you know no but yeah so
it's but it is a but but coming in like
that also helped me to meet people on
all different levels of comedy too and
then so and I see the people that are
like you know doing really well where
you're like I mean that person can just
walk in anywhere and then I also don't
have friends who were younger in comedy
where I'm like oh man I'm glad I didn't
come in yeah you know at three-year mark
because they're having a tough time like
they hate like just people at a light
man I don't know if I really want to
keep doing this here or I don't I keep
going what am I supposed to do or I feel
really frustrated because it is a lot
harder to get stage time if you are you
know if nobody knows who you are and if
you're not in at the clubs and things
like that and then there's um you know
and you still have people that you know
it's bringer shows where they're
standing outside like trying to get
people to come in to see the show so
it's just a lot of
a lot of stuff but for me it also just
the the everyday living part of New York
has been a really big adjustment and
it's also really hard as well so I would
think like you if you're doing that plus
also going oh wow I'm a I'm a fresh new
comic that's been doing comedy for five
years I'm gonna be in New York like it
is it is not easy I mean it's a lot like
I remember one of the first weeks that I
was there cuz I got the first month that
I was in New York I actually was only
there for like a total of three days cuz
I was on the book with it that was when
I had actually filmed the The Comedy
Central half-hour so I wasn't there but
and so when I was officially there just
like for days on end I remember just
being on the train one night and it was
just disgusting I mean like it was
absolutely sober and people were I mean
people like people were just it was just
I felt like every coffee landed on my
jacket like a like a wool coat and I was
like oh this has seeped into the fabric
of my spirit and I got it
you're like I gotta start wearing like a
I was I got a weird jacket with a
non-porous surface because this is to me
like so and in light that night I just
remember walking into the apartment and
I think the next day I just left and
went to DC and I just remember hitting
on my boyfriend I was like yeah I'm
gonna be there tomorrow he was like what
happened to you and I was like the train
it was just the trainer
how are you going and I was like be back
in a few days
like I just I just need to be in a car
and I just need to drive but is this an
adjustment I mean like and so it is it
is really hard if you're trying to
navigate comedy but then also trying to
navigate life because it's just it is a
lot is a lot mean if you are used to
being a person where you are you know
you're used to like hey
I've got of my car and now we're gonna
I'm gonna drive to Target real quick I'm
gonna go like in New York to me
everything is a thought process before
you go and do it where you're like oh if
I go to Target let me see
hmm should I have somebody deliver that
thing to me or should I get on the train
should I Boober and then when I think
they're okay like and since I don't have
a car I can only bring so much stuff
back or do I go to a place where I can
take my cart it really tests your love
for comedy you're like how what am I
willing to do yeah yeah and oh my god by
the way mica says hello to you
so which mica which hey Micah
Mei ke she's based in North Carolina but
she's a big fan of the show interview
but will we have a little under 15
minutes left with Mia so people start
commenting with your questions and one
common question I want to touch on real
quick is we were talking about New York
being a big struggle in transition but
right now our current situation is a big
little struggling transition so how have
you I mean for a lot of comics it's like
all my work is gone how are you
maximizing the time that you have now
and then how are you also making money I
had been minimizing okay I realize like
the big news I was traveling a lot and
just do it a whole lot of stuff so it's
like oh okay I can just kind of sit down
and I could recalibrate so I mean I have
been doing some stuff so like I'm a
friend of my like we're just we're
writing some stuff together so we can
pitch like I'm doing I'm doing that and
then what else hadn't really been like
sitting now going oh I'm gonna write
jokes today like I
I haven't done that because I haven't
been outside so it's like what am I
gonna comment on like oh man look at
that like the the covers changed like
what am i you know on the bed look we
got a new comforter like what am I gonna
no one has to I mean what am I you know
if I can't um you know I mean and I was
you can comment on the news and things
like that but it's like we're all seeing
the same thing so we're all gonna have a
lot of similar cakes and I'm you know
and that's the thing that's missing
where's like if you go outside you go
have some interaction with someone at a
store I'm not I'm not gonna have the
same interaction that another person I
haven't if we do we may interpret it in
different ways when we're consuming so
much over the same content that's why
you ended up seeing where you know
fifteen thirty thousand people have made
the same joke alike and not even comics
is people that are just everyday life
but um so you're focused on writing
you're still creating but not
necessarily for the stage but you're
actually like writing a script usually
using your creative muscle but in a
different way so that's what I've been
doing it like you know yeah money-wise I
mean like I was um you know uh luckily
luckily I saved some money you know so I
had some money saved and then and then I
still had like you know stuff that I did
earlier this year I was just waiting to
get money for them so I had that so like
I'm I'm okay for a little while you know
but you steal that thing where I'm like
oh I don't have anything but when that
okay for a little while
ian's I'm like oh god what am i what am
I gonna do like do I you know yeah so
I'm like I need to give me a work from
home job like I'm I still got a resume I
mean it's old but I still got you know
so who knows I don't know so you're
trying to figure it out like the rest of
us yeah I think yeah I think we all are
yeah yeah it's tough so oh we got Trent
Babb here he's tuning in from California
actually he's out in the Fresno area
I this is a fun one okay that said I
watched one of your Comedy Cellar sets
so you've been I've also been a part of
that
Comedy Central releasing these Comedy
Cellar yeah yeah this we get the cellar
yeah so he I watched one of your Comedy
Cellar sets and then one of your
corporate gigs the corporate gig was
more creative original and I think it's
because you weren't relying on the word
[ __ ] do you feel trapped by that word
at bar slash Club gigs no no no I don't
actually I hate corporate gigs to be
honest I I don't like them at all
they're not there I mean they're there
okay listen why you gotta tell me which
clip which clip that was but why do you
like me well corporate there are
parameters and you do have to be clean
and avoid words like at college but in
bar games maybe he's thinking of like we
got a bar like Club do you feel more
like a little more course my grandmother
I just said course mom was in Terris
language 7 you like me abettors but do
you feel yeah that may be a more
clarification no no I don't know I don't
I don't feel like I have to I don't like
what I'm doing a club said that I have
to rely on Kirsten I mean honestly I
like saying [ __ ] so I mean that's one
of my favorite favorite things like I'll
say it 15 times now count it down [ __ ]
[ __ ] no no I don't feel no no I don't
feel like I have to to say it I just I
mean I do like that at a curve I can do
whatever I want though like I do like
that because you can pretty much have
the freedom to say whatever you want and
and you know corporate gigs yeah there's
oh there's
different different minds if it goes
into it because you're like oh oh yeah
that's right I can't say what I want
here I have to to say stuff then they
want me to say or things that I want to
say but within their parameters so yeah
yeah but I mean but I like seeing [ __ ]
though so I hope that answers the
question
yeah and he said it was the Buckhead
theatre clip so okay yeah yeah awesome
oh he followed up - all right and just a
few more minutes here kids so know we
have more people watching but if you
have a question for me at toss it in
longer I'll stay a few minutes longer he
won't I was I'm not good to build demand
I was trying to build a sense of urgency
for people to post questions because
people were like so jazzed here you come
on and they were like me is awesome and
then now like nobody's really asking
questions but people are watching but
Trent followed up Oh Kathryn has another
one hold on did you wait for people to
approach you after gigs to start selling
merch I want merch but feel like I need
to wait for people wanting to connect
okay let me make sure okay are you
asking like would be you know when is it
the right time to sell much is that yeah
this is sound like he's saying like I
want to sell merch but don't think
people would care yet it's really it's
honestly this is the thing that's just
up to you like for the longest time I
didn't sell anything cuz I I kind of
thought it to where I was like oh who
wants something that I have like does
anybody want anything and then I'm like
huh then it was well what do I say oh
then I started selling like I just took
one of my jokes there - two jokes that
have like a catchphrase or you know or
something that I keep saying throughout
my set and then
I am I just was like all right I'm sorry
stay with me and if people buy it they
buy it and if they don't they don't but
I mean obviously you want to make sure
it's the right kind of show to sell
things at to cause like you're not gonna
go to a college show with a sale things
because college students I don't have
money to buy anything you probably also
aren't gonna do it at a oh it's a bar
show where you got paid 50 bucks tonight
you've got it and a drink ticket like
some sometimes you can sell stuff there
but sometimes you can't but I mean most
of the times it's better just to try to
sell at a club or it you know this
certain events where you know it's the
right thing to do and then you just go
and you just take it and I would just
say whatever you sell make sure it's
something that's not gonna break the
bank I mean like I'd sell koozies
they're super easy to travel with
they're super cheap to get made
sometimes I'd sell cups that have the
little phrase on it but but something
that's easy and that like you're not
looking back in two months going why the
hell do I have 75 t-shirts well why do I
have a bottle of hundred t-shirts that
I'm gonna have the donate because now I
don't anymore you know so yeah so it's
not a so it's a it's a yeah like it in
trust me if people want it if you're
standing it with something at the show
if they wanted it's not up to you would
be like I don't know if these people
have wanted they'll let you know if they
want it or not and you get the PM and
and one sometimes when you start selling
you'll give the people are like they
just want a little thing to remind them
of being at the show and then other
times you will have people they go I
don't want to remember this at all
and I will not give you eye contact on
the way out the door but yeah just take
a chance and take something but I also
start with something small and then just
kind of standing there but also make
sure you're very personable when you're
talking to people and don't have that
look of like I need you to buy this
thing that I'm selling because I you
know nobody wants to buy something
someone that looks like they're
desperate and falling apart yeah start
small something that travels easily I
found
koozies have been like I've done
t-shirts but like the koozies I I'll
sell them for five but I've had people
buy them for 20 I mean you know what I
mean like they'll just like give me a 20
and be like I want to support you and a
koozies a very low entry way for them to
do that yeah because I hear people I
mean I thought somebody came to me to
show one time and just was like here
again you think the book sort of the
last five you got and I'm like oh all
right exactly
and did you sell mugs at one time mmm
they're just just play originated ups
because I remember when we reacted the
Atlanta improv together when a I was
hosting you were featuring and Chris
Porter was headlining that was also a
weekend I forgot that was my first time
ever forgetting a headliners name I only
remembered the first name and I just at
the last second found it was like Chris
and he was like okay but I remember you
just killing all weekend and him being
like dude she's really funny and like I
think that was my first time seeing you
work a comedy club like night after
night and seeing you in action it just
lights out but I thought you were
selling mugs then but I guess it was
just cups plastic yes so we we hope that
helps Trent
so I mean start small and low entry and
low investment to the next one here Ryan
MacGuffin okay IRA the transition from
open mics to paid gigs seems like a bit
of a gray area to me can you expand upon
that
well yes I can I will do the best that I
can so you know it's a you know comedy
has it's different it's different levels
and in it's really just dependent on you
how long you stay at that level too so
obviously you start out you're doing
your open mics and you're just using
that time to try to get good and that's
what you want to use it for you want to
use it to build up
hey here is my first five minutes now I
got my 10 minutes oh so now if I got ten
minutes this means I could may be hosted
in a comedy club if you're doing open
mics at a club so that they can see you
and then you just keep building and
building your time up and then again
some of this stuff like it's not a why
there is that great areas because
they're really it's not like going
here's an entry-level job and then
here's the didn't you have apply to this
next level didn't you apply to this
thing you apply to that thing it's just
really the amount of time you're putting
in and where you're putting that time in
it so like for me when I started the
funny farm was open in in Atlanta and
then I would go there and I would do the
overnights a lot and then eventually got
booted from the open mic to a host but
it was because I was showing consistency
at the open mic level and in fact
talking about what I did first it was
over my fear they were like hey come to
a guest spot just to see if I could do a
weekend show then I started getting
asked to host and then the same thing
happened at the punchline as well I was
doing a lot of the open mics there and
then they were seeing me be consistent
at the open mics then it was eventually
hey welcome host in this particular
weekend and then that's how it kind of
started but it was just being consistent
but being consistent at those clubs and
then that started leaving me to get
others so for somebody like older she's
hosting at the punchline Errol she was
hosting at the funny farm so oh well now
we got this bar show here we're paying
25 bucks and drink ticket and some wings
so can you come do this other thing and
then I mean that's kind of how how you
get to that level but it's just I mean
always and then always do open mics too
like I tell people even now like I'm
never too good to do an open mic like I
mean I've had people you want to drop by
my mic tonight I'm like yeah I still I
still do that mic so that's just my
other side note my
that don't all you know still do them
because you can always work out material
but that's usually how it happens it's
just you're doing the mics you get
consistent at the mics people see that
you're doing well and then they go this
person is doing well enough here to
where they can do a booked and paid show
but you also have to go to the open mic
cuz I've known people who over the years
will feel like well I'm done to open mic
so where's my check done like well how
long does it take before I get paid in
comedy like I've seen that happen yeah
but so do you go go in and do the work
and what you do to work and be
consistent with it somebody's gonna
notice yeah I remember in one of our
other interviews you had a quote of work
gets work which is where and that's so
yeah yeah one of my friends told me it
really early in comedy he kept going
like work it's work because if somebody
sees you working then because I saw Joel
you know and Joel was killing the other
night so let me get him to come do my
show at this place I mean it because the
most merciless where you're gonna get
comes from other comments too so that's
also person so that helps yep being a
good co-worker treating the show like
your job but I think was super important
for people to remember is like you said
being consistently funny at open mics at
places where they are booking other
shows or like what's interesting about
what you just said is that's almost the
same formula you use to work up through
New York as well is it's like yeah
you're being consistently funny at the
Comedy Cellar where there are other
Booker's that see that then booked you
at other things yeah I mean is being
consistently funny you just other comics
yeah right yeah that's how they know
it's always yet it's usually yeah that's
kind of the progression as it is more
like you're in an open mic and
and a comic sees you and then book and
then like hey will you come do a spot on
my book Mike it's not necessarily paid
but it's a step up maybe you're on a
flyer now getting fancy and then from
there maybe they someone the audience
has a holiday party coming up they want
to book you for or like it's all starts
though good morning and let me also
clarify at the seller that's not an open
mic guys it's just anybody runs to it to
norcombe is like the the seller is the
top of the pyramid oldest comedy yeah
yeah no no but I'm saying even yeah even
you being there the same rules apply be
funny there and other people will want
to book you yeah oh yeah for sure yeah
because like I think I'll I'm trying to
think it's best Ben I can't even name
the amount of times I've just been
sitting around at the table eating wings
and somebody's like oh you know we got
to show it you know this other club you
know we got to show when got show in
Brooklyn or we got a show like come to
my show that our whole store don't come
to my podcast like I've been invited to
stuff just from hanging around with
somebody's like oh I see you here
multiple times yeah that's something I
wish I paid more attention to earlier on
no regrets but I do see the value in
just being around and being accessible
yeah yeah early on I would just go up
and then leave but yeah you got it you
got a hangout you got a hang it's part
of the job yeah another thing is you got
to be there all night long but you do
got a stick around and chat with people
you know just kind of and be cool later
work yes yeah and someone told me very
little I can also just don't be a dick
like that just one of the best pieces of
advice that I try it's true though
Carter Carter Bryant shout it's all
about he sent me he sent me a DM with an
image of you two together yeah I was
like
that's my favorite is when a guest is
like you know someone just came up to me
and said they saw me on hot breath it's
like it's like you're your late night
said or something like I saw you on hot
breath it was he said he loved your he
loved your makeup video also so all of
the don't rust challenge yes which they
took the music down on Facebook but if
you go to my Instagram you can actually
hear the song in the background that's
me a comedy and be a comedy yes so we
have another one here from I want to say
this right Sasha nikola CH saucony coal
which I think I know we have there's
listeners all over the world like word
we're in every continent except
Antarctica right now not saying that
sauce is not from America very well
could easily be okay anyway I'm too
white to say anything about race you
just settle yourself down what we call
her mamma mias she always knows the
place so salsa asked what some of your
favorite writing advice you receive that
has helped you out most in your career
[Music]
see the thing that helped me the most so
let me tell you about a girl named Mia
because when Mia first started Mia's me
by the way know when I first started I
used to just sometimes I was just get
offstage and just talk talk talk talk
talk and I would like have little random
pieces of paper with notes written down
and I remember a comment took me out to
the side and he was like you know you're
really funny he said but every time I
see you you're always talking about
something completely different in your
not working on the stuff that is working
in the stuff that has potential so why
don't you just write that stuff down so
best piece of advice I can say is one
record your sense record every single
one of them and then go back and listen
to that say and then transcribe that's
it and then when you transcribed and
said go back and take notes
see where people laugh and see where
they didn't laugh and just you know in
and also one of the things you can do
just as a comparison whatever joke
you're like oh I want to try this out
this is something I want to do the next
time I get on stage so you type the joke
write everything down from that joke and
then you try to commit you know back to
memory and now you got that written out
it so being with your tape next to the
stage record the scent and then
transcribe and then kind of look back
and forth to go oh this was how I wrote
the joke this is what I actually said
because a lot of times you know when
you're thinking of the written word
that's how how you always naturally talk
so sometimes when you're on stage things
will come out the way you naturally want
it to come out so then when you go and
look at those notes you're like oh hey
well I wrote it this way but this is
what I actually said and you know what
this actually sounds better or oh I
actually forgot this thing that I wanted
to say so next time I go on stage let me
add just one line in but you just go
through and give yourself you know like
I said oh this was the setup and this is
the punchline and oh this is the thing I
said by accident this person laughed and
then you start working from back as a as
a master document and you just keep
refining from that point on so that
usually helps me cuz there was one joke
that I had that I kind of had bits and
pieces of it and I kind of talked it out
just in conversation with friends and
then one night I went and did the joke
and I went oh that's like the best
version of that joke so far so this is
the one that I need to transcribe and
then from there there I started trimming
the fat on that joke and then I got it
as tight as tight as tight as possible
and that's the joke that I used to open
up a half-hour with what is that
trimming and Oh Sasha Sasha says love it
thank you and it's all it's pronounced
Sasha and I'm from Chicago so I'm so
sorry I hope we didn't lose a member of
the operetta person with this yeah
Lubin an article I meant I meant nothing
by it honestly I appreciate you spend
the time here with us and so yet to peel
it back another layer when you're
talking about I like you talking about
talking it out in conversation and
finding funny that way but then what is
that trimming of the fat process the
trim but it's just when you go through
and look at those notes and you're like
oh okay you know let's say you know I
got a four or five lines in the joke and
you're like oh they lasted this they
lasted this I wanted him to laugh at
this but they didn't laugh at this and
then and let's say you're gonna joke two
or three times and they're not laughing
at that line and just scrap it and now
you've taken that line out and now
you've tightened up their joke even more
cuz you're not singing that thing that
wasn't working anymore and I mean you
just keep doing that over and over and
over and over until it just until it
drives you crazy but yeah but it's this
is certain jokes I can remember like I
remember one joke I could do this was
years and years ago but I have to joke
about the bachelor and I'll do it
anymore but I would I just had all these
different things I'll be like and then
one day I remember recording it said and
then I was like oh these four or five
things I was rambling about no one even
cared no one even listened to that part
but I'm like but what I hid this part
and then I hit this line that's what
people responded to the most and then I
deleted those three or four lines that
weren't working and then the next time I
got on stage and I went oh now this is
the joke this is this is the the joke
now because I've gotten rid of the
things that are where I'm just talking
too much and then you know you'll hear
the phrase economy of words where I
least amount of words I can use to make
a point about something and so this is
like oh I was using way too many words
for that that joke what I was just
trying to say this one thing
yeah mark Normand mentioned that when he
was he was on here mentioning like yes
simplifying oh yes you and Mark fellow
you both went on tour with a me yeah but
yeah he talked about making the
simplifying the joke a lot of times we
try to over complicate it with words but
it really is about what are the min
amount of words and what is like making
the joke easily understandable as well
don't make it too like confusing or
clever yeah yeah and then in and then
sometimes and if something is too clever
there like if it's something that I
really like but I think is too clever
how do you do almost like a wink and a
nod after so I'm like guys you know what
that really was just all for me like
that was like I enjoy that I know you
didn't but I did
and then some people will be like oh she
acknowledged that that was the most
ridiculous thing she could have said so
yeah but yeah but you deal but you just
try to go listen what's the what's the
easiest way that I can say this because
you know what's the easiest way because
you know sometimes I think we assume you
know sometimes you like people won't
know what I'm talking about and there
are certain things where people won't
know but you have to you can even use
those things that they don't know as an
opportunity to teach in that joke too so
you can you can you can you know so
sometimes things that people don't know
you add to it and it some things there
are things that are widely known where
you're like oh I don't have to give this
much exposition and explanation I can
just get to what I'm trying to say and
you'll try a joke you said about like
three times or so before you kind of
just turn it out three or four times and
if I'm like oh they they keep laughing
at the same thing that they're not
laughing at this thing let me just drop
this part of this joke altogether
because this thing just isn't isn't
working and that's part that's part of
the discipline of being a comedian is
just honoring the data and being like
you know what no matter how much I love
this line and how clever this
alliteration was they don't they respect
my consonants here it's like if
at some point you gotta kill it you know
yeah right because you're like I can
keep I can keep right of it yeah and
I've you know have friends that I
alright with and I'll be like take that
line out like it doesn't no no I'm gonna
do it you know what go on suit yourself
yeah but that's always I learned from
you early on is I remember you and
Landry would write together a lot
another hilarious comedian oh you still
will so what all the time what do those
sessions look like what it what exactly
are you guys doing cuz I think I think
there's room for people here listening
and viewing and in this Facebook group
to like start maybe applying some of
these things um what we will do so when
I write this thing I'll start off with
not enough stuff and so he can then help
me like Philly in the blanks also when
he's like oh well why didn't you say
this or why didn't you say this thing
and I'm like oh yeah you're right and
then he writes a lot from the beginning
and so what I end up doing I'll either
you know get on a you know I'll go into
Google Docs and then I'd use P always
laughs cuz I use the strikethrough
feature so I'll be like wow you got rid
of a whole section and I'm like yeah
because you didn't need you didn't need
that part of me and he would go back and
read me he'll be like you know what
you're right it was like I didn't need
all this stuff and then when he gives me
advice I'm like you're right I didn't
say enough and I do need to say a little
bit more to you know like not not more
in the point where you know not more to
the point where I'm talking too much but
it's like oh I mean give just a little
bit more information to make this
punchline make sense so I didn't set up
me need to make a little bit more sense
I feel and each other the jokes in
written form and edit them that way cool
yeah yeah this is interesting this is
interesting take as well a Trent jumped
in here how quick does a new joke go
from pin to stage
um it just it depends like if it's
something I'm really really excited
about like if something happened and
I've had a conversation with someone
like and it's might have been the Joe
friend of this week at the cellar but
there was a since I've been in New York
I was noticing that a lot of people stop
and ask me for directions like this is
just a real thing in real life where I
was like why do people keep you know
people keep stopping me in the joke that
I and so in in the real life that I say
this isn't open in real life I was
walking down the street and this man it
was like hey you know I like your size
like I like I was like what he's like ya
know I'm in conversation telling you
know what my friend dude just told me he
liked my side and I was like I don't I
said what is that that mean I said is
that a compliment I'm like just he I
think it's mostly gonna be like I like
your shape but you know you got a fat
ass so you know some like that I said
but this dude is like and I said I said
what do you want him like are you
I said maybe he wants to recruit me for
a basketball team you know maybe you
know maybe he like what does he want for
me and so and so and so because I was so
excited talking about that in
conversation I was like oh you know I'm
a slide as then tonight on stage and
since I already have jokes about being
tall because I was so excited about him
like boom and then a joke started
working like right off the bat because
it was just a fresh thing but that I
have other drugs where I'm like ah you
know here's a story that I've told in my
personal life
privately offstage where my friends will
be like me and every time you turn a
story that story so funny and I'll be
like I really don't know if I wanna do
that one but yeah so it just it really
just depends like sometimes sometimes
it'll be if I'm really excited about
something I bite someone on stage that
night and I can slide it in I'll do it
but then I have other drugs so I'm like
I need a little bit more time on this
and I need to feel okay before I take
this to the stage and it's finally
really said that something you're
excited about
it's something you're like going to be
able to perform and really like deliver
and make believe yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah and then I got other stuff like I
said that I do I just like talking about
all stage but then I don't know if I
would necessarily say it on stage and
they're like because I had a job that I
started doing recently or just kind of
popping in and out of my set but it was
gonna sound in poor taste which is why I
have to preface this but I was um when I
was watching her when the Aaron
Hernandez documentary came out and and
so in conversation I was just telling
when I was like man you know I was
listen to the jailhouse conversation
between him and his fiancee and he asked
her to bring him some Harry Potter books
and then I was like even in that
conversation you could tell that she was
just over it like beyond him being a
murderer she was just like I wanna bring
these damn books you know and I was like
I said and I said you're in jail like
why do you want a whimsical fantasy
novel like why do you get to read books
about children Wizards when you're in
jail and like obviously you like
Slytherin and so and so I just and so
I'm just saying it just like a
conversation I went oh this makes me
chuckle it's like it's not typically
something I was talking about my sins
but I did it a few times and and I was
like guys I want to say this joke but it
might be tacky you're people like say it
say it and so obviously I'm talking a
lot about it right now saying a lot of
words but I did it more in joke form on
stage but like people we've been working
to like oh you're so silly you know but
it was like I was just interesting to a
fascinating conversation that I wanted
to do like and I think maybe a week
after I saw the documentary is what I'd
be at the joke so fun a lot of it is
coming from you being funny in
conversation which i think is very
helpful for me I I first heard that from
Clayton English and where he's like I
try to pay attention to how I'm funny in
real life and then get to the stage so I
that's I think it's best for newer
comics who are always like well how do I
use the math to make this word funny
it's like well how are you
naturally funny what are you now excited
about and that'll bring out your natural
voice on stage yeah like how are you
funny as a as a real person right
instead of get out of your head and
going and yeah and there is a formula to
things being funny like sure but yeah
but like I think some people get so
married to the idea of like it has to go
this way this way and this way but it's
like no logic why'd your friend laugh at
that story that you told him the other
day and and in and let me also add this
to it now after you become a funny
comedian on stage when you should not do
now don't now try to add jokes into
conversation with people like if
something organically comes up then poo
like it like if you're organically going
oh you know because everybody's on
watching Tiger King and if you're
talking about that and you're having a
funny conversation about that with
somebody and there's something you can
use from that sure but don't start off a
conversation going by the way the tiger
King crazy right like don't like no run
jokes on people like me like you'd have
an organic conversation with someone
cool but don't run jumps because comics
can tell like I've known so many people
over the years I've been like are you
doing a bit right now I'm like my wife
will do that with me yeah she can sniff
him out not by laughing but just by
calling him out of like don't do
material Trent said he he has I have a
transit worker body that was one of his
favorite lines of yours I have a dream
I'm glad he said because I totally
forgot that whole joke since I haven't
been on stage I'm like oh I didn't say
yes because that's that's on that's on
your Comedy Cellar set that was that was
this week at the sale because I said I
have a transit informational shaped body
and when I say that in New York like
I've read has been so funny because I
was going people keep asking for
directions like am i shaped like an MTA
worker like I must be like I must be
shaped like a train lady I'm a train
Lincoln and it's and I've had people
like one
I actually came with to me at a show
because I was so excited about telling
the drover he was like no I work for the
MTA and he was like you say better than
a MTA lady what a pick-up line how did
the the wording of that joke occur did
it just come out that where did you
rework the specific version I think how
was it I think I think I just blurted it
out one day like in like when I was I
think when when it happened when I kept
getting people asking me for directions
I kept going cuz and because it had it
in the street but it happens a lot on
the train or people like do you know
this one goes uptown or does this just
train go to such a such and I was like
oh no I have a transit body I have a
transit informational body you know my
other transit information shaped body
and so I'm like oh this like that's the
free like that's the and then I'll be
like I got training kiddies I'm trained
you know a bunch of different things
around that theme to see what sticks or
not yeah and then one of the one of my
tags to the joke cuz I end up saying
like you know the mic oh you know Mina's
lady just still standing there and I go
she won't go in the store and then I go
ma'am when you're going in the store or
not and she goes oh I'm going in and I
just go okay well then you need to stand
clear of the closing doors and like so
but that came about because one of my
friends heard it and he was like oh you
know what I think you can close that
joke out by making a train announcement
but I didn't know what the train
announcement will be and I was like oh
that's a good idea until the next time I
was on the train I just started
listening to all the train announcers
and I'm like oh pretty much any time
I've been on a train anywhere in any
city they always say stand clear at the
close of doors and then another thing
that I do because sometimes I'm
performing in places that don't have
mass transit sometimes I will drop that
line all together and I don't even just
say that where I go you know and I go
now I'm scared if I go to a city that
doesn't have mass transit I'm just gonna
have people running up to me
off the streets and have kids what I'm
not going when is my mom coming to pick
me up and I'm like I'll call her cuz I
have a transit body you know it's
alright other places too where go oh
it's this works in major cities but this
might not work in a small town um let's
get to these last two here
Trent Trent's piling him on here he's uh
like you said clever he's like being too
clever is a problem I have
it sounds preconceived do you think
these days people want to believe you're
coming up with it on the spot
for example puns rhymes etc I think if
you're doing poems and you're doing
things that are super clever like just
technology you know just like like I was
saying I think I mentioned it earlier
it's like if there's something that I
think this is really silly or I think
this is a ridiculous like you just like
you know what that's ridiculous and I
and I know that I mean anything like
people I think what people want to see
on stage they just they just want to
know that you're being yourself they
want to know that you're having a good
time they want to know that you know
that what you're saying is is real to
you so that it comes across as real to
them and because I don't know one time
it just as an example and it has nothing
to do with a clever part I remember a
conk who she kept talking about being
married and having kids on stage and it
was she got offstage I was like you're
not married you don't have kids and I'm
she was like she bursts out and she was
like how'd you know and I was like is
something that just made me like I knew
she was like oh that's so funny cuz she
was like some people like don't always
know that it she was like yeah I just
made up this whole whole thing you know
and so like so I think people want to
see you being real and so if something
is a very clever thing and you
acknowledge that it's a clever thing you
can say it and you can also say it
without being a jerk to people you can
be like like not because I've seen I've
also seen comes gonna be like that one
went over your head guys and you know
you like I've seen it I think but if you
lie truth
I like puns guys you're gonna hear these
all night so you could get witnessed so
you don't get with it you know what I
mean so like if you got a bunch of puns
say all that [ __ ] back to back and I'm
gonna keep doing so you get with the
pond so you don't get with you know
we're gonna have fun tonight you know
just tell ya if it's authentically you
then they're they'll go along with you
that's what I was sure all right and oh
he likes it he says that's great
acknowledge the silliness thank you so
the final question here is harder mister
hold on let's get a drumroll
from Wayne flake jr. he said what we
always hear about he spelled here h e re
but we won't worry about that we all
wait that was oh that was you put Sasha
in Antartica and now now this is this
what the quarantine is open I'm sorry
Wayne oh man Wayne's because you're us
here at wait you're right he says we
always hear about what to do when
writing jokes what are some things we
might want to avoid oh let's see well
we're not gonna worry about grammar
[Laughter]
something what do you want I mean like
the the don't be too married to the idea
of going I have to type this exactly
either right that's exactly how it's
gonna sound on stage because there will
like I've mentioned that earlier there
will be some variations so the maybe
like I always just tell people like
don't like just don't be like it
I have to say this this is like one just
get it out your system so that's the
main thing like don't don't limit
yourselves when you're writing don't go
oh I mean let me edit this before I even
say it like no just write it all down
like so don't even just get it
any and everything you want to say on
that topic write it out like get it all
out of your head so then and I still
suffer from that sometimes well go wall
I don't want to say this thing and I'm
like wait why do why do I not want to
say that thing like let me just say it
first and be it out make the decision so
the main thing is you know just don't
don't edit yourself before it gets on
stage don't live it yourself just let it
all out get it all out very nice
all right I love that that's a good one
that's a good one to end on I think I
mean it's really is just don't limit
yourself really yeah oh and he called me
um a grammar nazi so I apologize hey
just because that blonde hair blue eye
doesn't mean I'm not okay right your
your face is triggering for people
really is it's yeah it's yeah it's all
well deserved though well earned no well
I mean there are some systemic things we
don't have time to discuss you're right
right your fault
you're fine no I'm one of the good ones
though thank you me I get a better pass
you just you just told yourself you were
one of the good ones
I know I'm really big and I'm really big
in here anyway you know it is time for
us to land this plane before we do get
out of here is there anything else that
you want the world to know no no no no
no right you know right go you know we
got a lot of time right now so go listen
to some of your sets that you've
recorded go watch them see what kind of
things you can make some adjustments you
mean you won't be able to perform in
front of anybody right now but start
taking some notes and
and you know what also chill out to take
some time to chill like it's been a lot
of memes going around with people like
you need to come out of this quarantine
with a new business towel they've done
you know my own time I wouldn't do
business if I don't have nobody to sail
to [ __ ] to like come on like I don't
know if I could curse and I've been
cursed exactly let it go point is it's
like don't I also don't don't feel
pressured by the quarantine to have to
create I mean if you feel like right and
do it and then we do have those limbs
where you feel like doing it like I said
listen to you said watch videos watch
some other comics and watch the other
comics to learn it's a lot of great
comedy on Netflix and Comedy Central and
it's so much stuff on you too but just
you know see what other comics are
talking about it picks them in your
favorite comics and watch you know see
how those peoples are structuring their
material watch some of their earlier
said from watch some of their later says
yeah they have all real retire so yeah
go go - Joel Byers comedy calm and check
out that comedy special and see how a
trophy husband comedy special now
available yeah I mean I comedy just
turned 10 I really saw my ten-year
anniversary on February 1st so it's like
we're getting up there Mia you're out
here your 10 year old and comedy hello
feels good well yeah you have I mean you
have been amazing to come on here and be
so generous with your time and
information but also just throughout my
comedy career you've been beyond helpful
and generous also with your time off
stage I learned so much from you just as
a friend and as a piercing you work so
much so all your success is so well
earned and deserved and I look forward
to like continuing to see this
trajectory you're on it's people and
people that join this live QA you are
you are witnessing greatness so thank
you so much for being a part of this Mia
thank you thank you
we'll see y'all again goodbye hot breath
averse oh and where can I support you
Mia
comedy
come Jackson okay then I'm on Twitter
and Instagram I'm at Mia comedy and I'm
on Facebook too so you can find me if
I'm if someone's friends with you then
they can be friends with me because I
have one of those pages where you got to
be friends with somebody too bad me okay
so yeah yeah awesome
well yeah go support Mia go watch her
Comedy Cellar set and her Comedy Central
half-hour and you'll learn a lot in
context for what we talked about today
so Mia Jackson thank you for being on
hot breath live thank you alright
[Music]